this is a production of Cornell
University alright so seriously my name
is Chris Fernandez fourth-year student
with Michael Mazurek and you can tell
from the title I mean I talked with you
today about how we're trying to leverage
genomics and our squash breeding program
I could have also easily called it gain
from three cycles of genomic selection
and squash but that seemed less exciting
so I find that most people aren't super
well acquainted squash so I figure I'd
include some fun facts the front here so
squash we want to talk about squash are
usually talking about three cultivated
species species that we eat that we work
with and those are curative pepo which
is there we go through the people which
is your acorn delicata pumpkin
jack-o'-lantern type of squash Jakarta
Machado which is like your butternut and
we have the Hubbard group and others in
maxima and so these are the three main
squash that work with these are examples
of winter squash so there are two kinds
of squash winter squash in summer squash
winter squash you eat mature summer
squash you eat immature like zucchini
and so I'm also gonna be talking our
exclusively going to be talking about
winter squash and so yeah squash has
recently been sequenced all of three
genomes um it's got like a super small a
rabid offices sized genome but like 20
chromic pairs of chromosomes just kind
of cool um other fact that i want to
point out is squashed already like
overflowing with nutrition do you eat a
half cup of squash you get 110 percent
of what you need a vitamin A that you
needed for the day so when we talk about
breeding like improving squash fruit
Paul you're mostly talking about making
it more appealing to consumers so that
they'll take they eat something that is
nutritious for them
I just said squash fruit quality when I
talk about fruit quality and squash I'm
talking about color sugar and starch so
color is mostly dictated by a carotenoid
content and squash fruit if you can
measure its HPLC or with color immature
sugars um effect sweetness of the squash
fruits use a reflector to measure that
and then starch affects texture and we
measure that with dry matter which is
highly correlated trait for that and so
our main project goals as I mentioned
are to use genomics and integrating that
into our breeding program so today I'm
also gonna be focusing on how are you
how we used you know in the current
selection to in our program I'm also
doing work it's more at aimed at
understanding squash fruit quality or
whether its components how are they
inherited I probably won't have time to
get to that today so mostly about
genomic slash and stuff so like I said
we're talking about how we've
implemented genomic selection in our
program so before I get into genomic
selection I want to talk briefly about
what the phenotypic collection cycle
looks like so it's a year-long cycle we
have one cycle of selection that happens
after we phenotype so we have to grow
squash in the field we get the fruit we
bring those fruit inside these are like
50-pound bags of squash that we hand
carried low into the truck and bring
inside so I like to say that squash
green is a full body workout so we feel
type it at the fruit stage just means
that we only select on the female parent
and you only have one cycle of selection
it's very labor intensive but the main
problem with squash is that it's the
Hummer of the plant world
so squash consumes tons of resources and
takes up tons of space so this is a
squash field here it might look like it
has a lot of plans
that's only 200 plants so we can't have
super huge populations also in the
greenhouse same problem this is like 20
plants here maybe and then storage this
is one experiment that we need to
harvest and ever that we need to process
before it rots so space and time
constraints are all issues that we
really have to try to deal with in
swashb reading more so I think than a
lot of the crops um
one way that word so we're trying to
implement genomic selection to try to
sort of get around some of these
problems so we're using genomic
selection to where genotyping at this
stage before a plant and then we can get
the data back and make selections before
flowering so we're controlling both
parents and then also we're doing
another cycle of selection in the
greenhouse so we can get two cycles of
selection per year and control of both
parents so that's how and also at some
point we update the model because we get
phenotypes as we're going so this is
sort of how we're trying to use Joma
collection overview we're doing it we
didn't buy principal because it's easy
to start population to do it in and you
know it's already enough of a challenge
for us to try to integrate this squash
program so I figured we just keep it
simple or doing with a current selection
scheme with 200 plans so it's popular
slightly top 10% for bricks try matter
and color values and once again keep it
simple keep it G blow up doing multiple
traits so we use the multiple trait
model where we're basically selecting on
one value at the end which is just equal
weighting of all three of these fruit
quality trait values that we get from
the model so that's how we're doing
selection so f2 between Honey Nut and
bugle we chose those because we've used
them in our program a lot and you drive
some very nice F stick lines from them
so we know there's potential so that's
why it's perfect test for our genomic
selection pilot study feed Civic data
the main takeaway here is that all of
our traits are normally distributed
quantitative traits they're correlated
in favorable directions so we should be
able to get high bricks high dry matter
and then high color value which is what
we want so sort of what we're looking
for here some very elegant genetic
parameter figures for you
bricks dry matter have similar
moderately no kind of low here debility
is color value a slightly higher
heritability and all the traits as we
would expect are gently correlated
defeated before they're also gently
correlated this is just from the multi
trait model and get the head
um this wonderful jiwa cos slide here is
supposed to show you that those traits
don't really have any major effect low
size so it makes sense to use genomic
selection in this situation so then I
have some cross validation results so we
have the base population and then
another population that we used to
retrain the models see we have a
moderately strong cross-validation
values so can't do super good super well
we can do we do okay especially in this
only retrain the model we had some
better data I think we're able to do a
better job so we actually did selection
too so we we have crossed by a shy
Cruces and we set up the scheme so I did
one R I did one around a few to the
selection followed by three rounds of
genomic selection and then this year I
grew out all from remnant seed the
populations at three field sites
randomized complete block design look at
gain from selection so these are
results so here we have three
populations block two three locations
sorry about two weeks with cut and
organic and we have a base population up
through the final selected population so
space population after future big
selection after an intermediate showing
selection around and then the final
round of selection and so you can see in
most locations it looks like we enriched
for individuals with higher index values
so this is we don't have this population
in this environment but for the most
part it looks like general collection
work for us we were able to improve
enriched for higher index value
individuals I don't have a picture of it
and I don't think in the slides but also
if you look at each of the traits of
bricks try matter at a value you also
see that each of the traits also
increased so increase total index but
also we increased all the traits
slightly so so we wanted to see there so
further work I mean obviously there's a
lot we could still do what this data
said so we're looking at looking at
correlated gained from selection other
traits so we measured laying with weight
yield traits and so we can look at what
happened to these traits as we selected
for fruit quality traits looking at
realized heritability a gain for cycle
you can already kind of see that but um
so yeah we're gonna be doing all that
stuff looking at inbreeding that sort of
thing also I save pedigrees from this
stuff so we can look at how well better
you slept or using just pedigree
information we've done for us use that
to compare with genomic selection and
then squash green 3.0 which I say is
figurin dirtier so bigger I mean larger
population size and earlier just cheaper
lower quality DNA extractions doing more
plans so I think we're kind of looking
because we have sort of low lower
prediction accuracy is doing more of a
genomic enrichment situation where we're
screening you know a couple hundred
plants as squash seedlings throwing out
like the bottom 50% and proceeding from
there and then also looking at looking
at some of these post storage quality
traits that we have in squash this is an
example of hollow neck which is not
desirable and I would see inside this
about squash four months special storage
conditions so we could develop
prediction miles for this trade that
would be super cool so
sort of we're looking to go I'm
I have a minute all right so really
quickly
just so you know we're also interested
in understanding fruit quality in Cuba
and we're interested in understanding
how this varies within species and
between species also you know just look
at how we can potentially bring together
different species to get what we want in
squash quality and so the experiment
I'll just tell you really quick as we
did we have data from different time
points and squash development at
different cultivars we did a bunch of
while we did a bunch of quality trait
measurements look at profiles and or
combine that with sheen expression
profiles to try to understand better
what's driving squash fruit quality
within species in between species so
that I'd like to acknowledge my adviser
Michael Mazurek my committee overly
leaves here right now Jessica Kowski
who's in the Philippines also the
chorim's Uruk lab our wonderful lab tech
field tech and the rest and also various
other individuals who've helped me along
the way and our funding source for this
grant from the USDA nifA grant and I
guess with that I'll take any questions
that you have
[Applause]
so the question is when how often we
retrain the model and one of the visuals
that I used to do that so I had Asterix
in here somewhere but they disappeared
but here we train the model initially
and then this is a green house
generation and then this is a field
generation so we retrained at this point
and that did these two this last cycle
using the retrained model so this is we
retrained at this point here and
actually I ended up just using the c2
population as a new training population
I didn't try to combine the two
populations because there's some the
data quality was just a lot higher in
this population that specifically the
GBS libraries were a lot better we got
higher quality genotypes so I just
decided to go with that so that's what
we end up using narky I have
that yet so I mean look at the raw data
but there's some outliers and stuff in
there so it's kind of hard to tell
whether we've reduced variance and I'm
sure there's probably been some
inbreeding though that also might be
part of the reason in addition to higher
quality while we have maybe slightly
better prediction accuracy as we still
have variation where they're more
related so that could be a reason that I
have higher accuracy is here but yeah I
haven't looked at that yeah we
definitely will look at that Thanks all
right let's thank Chris one more time
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu